hey everybody it's Mike reader here with
on-call compliance Solutions and I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week this week we're talking about cmmc
control mp.l 2-3.8.1 protect IE
physically control and securely store
system media containing cui both paper
and digital
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all the cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliant stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance hero
let's jump into it let's jump into it
let's jump into it I don't really jump
on camera actually so I don't know why I
keep saying let's jump into it it's more
like let's roll into it because that's
kind of more my speed but
you seem pretty energetic so let's just
jump into it together like we'll hold
hands we'll just jump into the foam pit
like at gymnastics you tell I have kids
that might be part of it okay so here we
find ourselves formalizing what I think
is oftentimes not really common sense
like this entire compliance standard
most companies typically have at least a
few Rogue thumb drives and portable hard
drives just laying around they're
unmarked who knows what on them and of
course when it comes to having cui on
the environment uh well that's just
really not cool not not so cool at all
all right so what needs to happen with
that stuff well if it was us we would be
asking everyone to immediately turn in
all thumb drives and portable hard
drives the it office within 24 hours
we'd be serializing them uh identifying
them logging them and of course putting
some cui stickers on them and entering
them into a cui media access log
everyone that has those portable storage
media devices and why they have them
along with what the intended use is so
again really truly keeping track in
inventory of what you've got going on
there
and we would be training those same
Personnel on device checkout that you
are not allowed to leave these devices
unsecured and they must be locked up or
physically physical physically secured
somehow and be able to be accounted for
the digital cui well that already should
be locked down by permissions most
likely but let's see what the assessors
are looking for on this one
okay so uh determine if paper media
containing Cy is physically controlled
okay uh all paper media is securely
stored in Lock storage containers where
uh when not in use uh temporary
temporary secure facilities uh may be
constructed or used in order to protect
cui depending upon project needs again
every facility is different everyone has
different ways they need to solve that
second assessment points determine if
digital media containing cui is
physically controlled is it I don't know
digital media is physically controlled
including locking server rooms
serialized and controlled portable
storage media specifically for cui and
cui media access logs determinive paper
media containing CI is securely stored
implemented all paper media is securely
stored in Lock storage containers when
not in direct use
next one determine if digital media
contains UI securely stored
is it the same
it looks the same but there's a c and a
d that's weird
oh one's paper media one's digital media
you see how easy that is to miss one of
these assessment points it's so easy
first one was all paper media is
securely stored next one is all digital
media is securely stored in Lock storage
containers and servers you know all that
kind of stuff you get the point so hey
uh at on call we work with defense
contractors to catch little mistakes
like that because we're very very very
uh detail-oriented that's what we are
yeah very detail-oriented uh and we work
with defense contractors just like you
who have had this defars nist itar and
cmmc compliant stuff dropped to their
laps like a seagull on a sunny day we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminated gaps great areas and
getting this solved all showing you how
to leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you if you're looking for more
help getting compliant our compliance
experts are always on call for you visit
cmmcc compliance secrets.com or check
out the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better
the Subscribe button
I mean how else are you going to be able
to see the awesome amazing content that
we're putting out here for you guys
right I mean like YouTube will kind of
tell you but it's way better if you're
subscribed then when I drop new content
you can be like
hey Jimmy
dude oncologists drop new content
and I got an alert about it so subscribe
this is awesome that's exactly what
you're gonna do boom boom it's the
brilliance
and then you can go and have some sushi
afterwards because Sushi and listening
to me go together like
yum yum sauce on everything
already then with that until the next
compliance tip my friends
stay safe and secure out there and let
us know that you want to know more about
in the comments below
peace
[Music]